islamic state was running rampant all
over
northern iraq a few years ago the
indigenous yazidi community
was bearing the brunt of the jihadi
atrocities perhaps
more than anyone else
[Music]
now some kind of senior figure within
isil ranks
must have been behind all this right one
of the accused is current islamic state
leader al-mawla
and guess what the release documents
reveal the man was once a prisoner
of the u.s military and provided the
pentagon with
extensive intelligence before being let
go
in several reports al-maula advised u.s
forces at the best time of day
to find islamic state in iraq members in
different locations around mosul
for example describing a specific cafe
where operatives met daily
detainee seems to be more cooperative
with every session
what else do we learn from the
declassified reports al-mala
was an absolutely precious asset for the
interrogators
he revealed the identities of terrorist
leaders provided map-like directions on
how to find them the man even pointed
out the phone numbers of
19 jihadi officials as well as pay they
got for their
jobs so to say the current head of isil
once betrayed the group's deputy
commander to american interrogators to
then take his place
this led to a u.s military op in which
the second
in command of the islamic state
predecessor group was killed in 2008.
think guantanamo think of plenty of
other individuals
imprisoned by uncle sam you can't help
wondering how the hell
almallah walked free the point it
happened at
is unclear too but the last
interrogation reports
mentioning him are dated july 2008
so what's with the release was it a
stupid accident
a major system faux pas or maybe someone
thought
the guy would never really cause trouble
well then the story of isil's now dead
former boss
abu bakr al-baghdadi should ring a bell
the fact that al baghdadi
you know got his start in an american
prison
isn't unique uh there are many people
including this this current uh
uh isis leader the american prisons in
iraq have been uh
described by many as um an incubator
for al qaeda an incubator for isis um
you know he's not a one of uh scenario
uh
there were hundreds of uh prisoners
thousands of prisoners like him
many of whom cooperated um all of whom
were eventually released
i think it's part and parcel of the lack
of strategic focus that
has plagued the united states in terms
of
its interactions in the middle east
since the
very bad decision to invade and occupy
iraq back in 2003
we haven't made a good decision since
then almaula turned out to be the
immediate successor
of al-baghdadi after he was eliminated
in a u.s raid in syria
in 2019. today washington has a bounty
of
10 million dollars on almala's head well
after all it's the u.s that once
spearheaded the war on terror
and remains the most successful force in
ridding the world
of the evil or maybe something has gone
wrong
with how it's done we've killed
isis members by the tens of thousands if
not hundreds of thousands the same with
al-qaeda
and yet they exist because killing
people does
not destroy the ideology uh the ideology
is sustained by the continued american
presence
uh in the middle east um there's this
unlawful presence in iraq and syria
uh and elsewhere so you know until which
time
we can diffuse that which motivates
these people to support isis isis will
always exist no matter
who's in charge and how many of their
leaders we kill i mean
it's a vicious cycle the the american
presence in the middle east
creates isis and the continued struggle
against
isis is used to justify the continued
presence of the american military
in the middle east which creates isis
and it's just a circle that goes on and
on and on and we'll never end until
we get out of the middle east